[man] I just can't believe
you're gonna lose.
Yeah. Yep.
[Mitt] So, what
do you think you say
in a concession speech?
By the way, someone have
a number for the president?
- [man] I do.
- Okay. [laughs]
Hadn't thought about that!
[Tagg Romney]
And if you don't win,
we'll still love you.
[laughter]
The country may think of you
as a laughingstock,
and we'll know the truth,
and that's okay.
[crowd]
Mitt! Mitt! Mitt!
[Mitt] This is
a very different setting
than any of the debates
we've held so far.
A dining room conversation
is among members of the family.
These are all people
competing for the same job.
How in the world do
we find these things out
on the day of the debate?
He hates to disappoint.
[Ann] Are you going to
iron it on you, seriously?
- [Ann laughs]
- It's working.
- Ouch.
- [man] This may not end well.
[man] A recent poll said
that 43% of Americans
are not even sure
who you are.
- The Flipping Mormon.
- [man laughs]
- How did you feel
on the stage?
- I was dying.
[Ann] I would not want
to do this again.
It's too much.
[Mitt]
I have looked, by the way,
at what happens to anybody
in this country
who loses as the nominee
of their party.
They become a loser for life,
all right?
That's it. It's over.
Barack Obama
has changed our race,
has changed our prospects.
He's a very good debater.
He's a lot better
than the other guys.
He's a much more effective
debater than they are.
[Josh] He's just getting
beat up constantly.
"Oh, Mitt Romney's
a flip-flopper.
He's this, he's that."
And I go, "Man,
is this worth it?"
[Mitt] And it's like
trying to convince people
that Dan Quayle is smart,
all right?
You're not going to convince
them that Dan Quayle is smart.
And maybe I've got
to live with that.
"Oh, you flip on everything."
In which case, I think
I'm a flawed candidate.
[announcer]
Please welcome
the next president
and first lady
of the United States
of America...
[cheering]
[man] A year ago,
we told you we'd love you
no matter how this thing
turned out, and...
- Now you're not so sure.
- Now we're not so sure!
[laughter]